look at the developed marine sonnet
blocking the android team and today we are
design byte let's talk a little bit
responsive or responsible design and
design is because this is very important
to ours that has several types of screen
for the platform screen sizes
android it is important that your app
be prepared to function for
perform well on any type of screen
no you do not want to lose the user
because then the expectation began
it was ugly or it was difficult to use, right?
finally, it's very complicated you have to
preparing for this is good
he is seeing there an example of a screen
that has a small first problem
excessive line length thing
look there is a tablet of 7 of 10
inches and I'm leaving a line
taking all the width is this is a
little that's necessary and then it's over
creating a visual discomfort when the
user is looking at this application and
even when he turns to the
vertical or portrait mode ends
happening and ground of content
unbalanced where I have there
content that is not taking advantage of
correctly the space
so you have no idea of
uniformity in content do not stay here
is something that pleases the view of the user of
person using the good age
The thing we have to think about is to use the
available space
but it's not just going out by putting a
lots of stuff
in the space available is
simply quit filling you can
even polluting the screen if you
to think about doing this a
tip then we start doing
reorganizations on the application screen
the first thing combination so I have there
is to follow the most basic example
those who already move the movement must
since this is an example fragment
it's ok, it's where I have two screens that
I have one after another and it ends
being unbalanced are content
it's too much, one person can combine
these two screens and this is the most
classic already has a list that
or select the item or update a
another panel on the right
not only because it is a list it can
for example a map on the side
left has some landmarks
I want to do a stretch of the way.
only a list of items
specifically in detail may be a
interaction between these two screens in which
Gotta keep coming back for an hymn to stay.
altering this content also filled with
macro reorganization where I have there in
I show a certain combination a
on top of each other and then when I go with
a larger screen
I do not have to go even space anymore
vertical but I have more space
horizontal I can also move to
divide the screen better between two panels
so why an organization that I am
using the two two screens in a way
higher for each and even then
combining well is these two these two
layouts né
and also has an example here is the
micro-redevelopment where I have one
conduit in the minor layout
I have little information, and when
I'm back to the bigger team.
I'll use a new way of
to organize in the case of
left, we have the type of
layout for example is very cool you
have some cards as information
underneath gives a dynamic gets more beautiful
the application is the images become more
pleasant
another tax than we have the
example on the side where I kept this
same line so same content I
centralized it emotive white space
on the side you see nothing has said to
fifa filling the space use the
space not always fill is sometimes
to balance I took this was
I waved it off a little
but I did not just have a screen with the
available space of the year
so you've reorganized it in a way
but also did not
all spaces
ok good folks these were some tips
how to make the application more
responsive to different types of screen and
species sizes have liked
in the years to come